>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC
[ Music ]
>> Seven hundred and
fifty seven million adults
around the world cannot read or
write, and 2/3 of them are women.
In the United States one
in six adults cannot read anything
more complex than a TV Guide.
At a global and national
level, the economic costs
of low literacy rates
are staggering,
and then there are the children.
Sixty one million children
around the world
who are elementary school
age, aren't in school.
Here in the United States,
34% of children entering
kindergarten don't have the basic
language skills to be
ready to learn to read.
It's inconceivable that such large
literacy deficits exist today given
the vast resources available.
So here, at the Library of
Congress, it's our mission
to provide the American people with
a rich, diverse, enduring source
of knowledge and the ability
to read and write is critical
to fulfilling that mission.
It's why we support the thousands
of organizations around the world,
working to promote literacy,
advocating for change
and empowering families, adults and
children to learn to read and write.
Literacy offers so many
life-enhancing benefits.
People who read, and do read are
healthier, happier and live longer.
They are more likely to
get preventative healthcare
and less likely to go
to an emergency room.
Globally, women and girls who
are educated have fewer children,
and those that they do have
are twice as likely to survive.
Everyone benefits from literacy.
For every 1% increase in
a country's literacy rate,
there is a permanent 1.5% increase
in their gross domestic product.
David M. Rubenstein's
creative vision
and generosity support the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards.
Each year, the Literacy
Awards program recognizes some
of the most innovative and effective
organizations promoting literacy
in the United States
and around the world.
Through these awards, we
celebrate literacy organizations
and the dedicated people who,
through passion and hard work,
are bringing education and
literacy to an unprecedented number
of people around the globe.
We hope to inspire others to emulate
these groups and to do their part
to help end illiteracy in their
own communities and beyond.
We still have a long
way to go, together,
we're making tremendous progress.
[ Music ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.